今日はこちらスティッカー分です今日は愛かまず言葉の勉強についての話ですけれども
もう
2019年はもうそろそろ終わりますのでこの新しい土地に向かってその新年の抱負
ですか新年の決意をですね
まあ彼がいている人もいると思いますじゃあ言葉の勉強について
どういう風なその新年の抱負
新年のその新しい年を何をするかと考えるとですねうん僕は非常にを大切なメッセージ
はね
言葉の勉強の目標は何ですか
木曜なのために言葉を勉強するからどう
それが大事なんですよ目標がないとそのなかなかうまく前へ進まないと思います
何どんなことをやってもですね
で
僕はす一番言葉の勉強の中ですね
大切な目標
それは楽しみなのために言葉を勉強するかっていうとそれが楽しみのためテストの為
じゃなくて
その楽しみたいと楽しみが目標であるば
必ず全て他の a
夢んですね
レベルが必ず上がるんですよ良くなるんですよ
で楽しめがないと非常に a その進歩するが
も近しいそれ以上に基本的な
要素なんですよ非常に有名なハンガリーの
そのポリロッドですねこれらというのはあるのにの通り
たくさんの言葉話せる人間が
ポリグロット言うんでしょうは英語で
水それもまあ日本語にもなってはいると思います
この間福岡でその
ポリロッテの会議がありまして食で
もうヨロッパ六兵衛アジア日本語を含めていろんな初夏子が来てまして
にしようっています
そしてそのうち
本当に流暢にもう一ツモ
たくさんのことを話してたえ
日本人もたくさん参加してたんですが
ただ日本ではまだ英語の勉強は一番メインなんですよ
ながら他の言葉でも英語でもですね
やはりその楽しみとそしてハンガリーのポリロッドの非常に夢奈公式なんですよ
言葉の勉強で生協するにはですね成功ずにはやはり
コーヒ気が合うんですよ
一つは人の態度勉強するとの態度いいよく地震
スキーが嫌いですねその他移動もう一つは時間
どれほどの時間をその言葉で使うからだそりゃ読む
ピーク話各そのこととその言葉を使う時間と割るの
その
を奨励
フラストレーションネガティブな感情
それが非常にマイナスになるんですよだから
楽しみランボー不要であれば態度も呼ぶな
そしてそういうネガティブなものは少なくなる
そしてたくさんの時間をその言葉と
使う
使いたいから退いた読みたいこの平和な a 55分なる10号でやはりこの言葉を
使いたいとそういう風の楽しいか見られたんだ
だからテストとか文法の説明とか
学校で教えているそういうすべてのものがそう
出会うマイナスじゃないけれどあまりに大雪紹介し大切なのは楽しみで勉強我々みんな
言葉を
自分のために勉強するんですよ楽しいから
だから他の人も批判数分もよくない
先生も私は訂正するにも
あまり役に立たない
楽しく勉強を続ければ自ずから良くなるから今
起こしたそのミスが版と肥後はあるいは
自ずから改善されるわけですからただいまテストでこれはダメ
これはぺ系これはためそういうのはですねあの
楽しい
実にあまり貢献しないわけですよそういう学校でのその伝統的な
その教え方がその楽しみをそのまま防ぐわけですよ
よくないんですよだから楽しみが目標
それは先生にとってもために
おいておかないとダメなんだしその勉強する人も
ハローどうやって楽しむだから
面白いなよう読むか皮膚が
自分が好きな人と一緒になって名義の英語中央
リングお話しするとやはり楽しく
楽しみというのが一番の目標
で自分に対する非常に批判できない対応
僕はよくない思うほど甘うまくいかないとかそういうのが全部だめだ
んですよその勉強する過程自身が楽しいであればそれですでに
モグ酔うたしたわけですよ楽しく勉強してるからそれは目標だから
人じゃなきゃ描かれそのて続ければ自ずから
良くなるから
だから
新年に向かって
何よりも楽しく勉強できる方法あれは態度態度も大事
今僕はちょっと極端ですけれどもよろしく覚えとることをオ g 勉強しているけれど
も勉強しているときにですね
何か読んで聴いているときにそれが今
僕がやり替えやりたいことですよとその辺の
だけだいや本当は他のことをやりたいとかやる価値があるかないかとかそうじゃなくて
やはり今それが大事それが楽しい
そういうふうな積極的な態度であのー
自分に対してあのーなんですが親切
ちゃん扱ってもらうとそれが非常に大事ですよね
まあそういう考えで新年に向かって皆さん来年も
その
[音楽]
まあ新年おめでとうございますそしてやはりのところ勉強で成功するためにはプロセス
過程が楽しく
べき夜のは目標それを頭においてくださいそれじゃあ
バイナラ